und markus faber wird hier auch als
erstes dann dazu sprechen mitglied der
fdp-fraktion die war bis vor kurzem
verteidigungspolitische sprecher
aufgrund eines kleinen e class in seinem
ausschuss ist er das nicht mehr sitzt
aber noch im verteidigungsausschuss
meine damen und herren heute ist tag 1
100 von putins angriffskrieg auch die
ukraine und es wird leider nicht der
letzte tag sein seit 100 tagen weiß auch
jeder hier im saal dass wir in einer
neuen realität leben und dass diese
realität bleibt diese realität dass ein
staat in europa einen anderen staat
grundlos überfällt wir haben eine
realität in der menschen schutz suchen
sie suchen schutz vor raketen die so ein
schutz vor artillerie und sie suchen
schutz vor den russischen
invasionstruppen und wegen dieser neuen
realität haben wir eine zeitenwende und
wir haben eine zeitenwende hinter der
sich zum glück ein sehr sehr großer teil
dieses hauses versammelt nämlich die spd
die grünen die fdp und
dankenswerterweise auch die union und
das ist das richtige diese zeitenwende
müssen nicht nur am kopf ankommt sie
muss auch in der realität ankommt und
dafür setzen wir gerade einen sehr
wichtigen punkt mit diesem
sondervermögen und deshalb möchte ich
mich
deshalb möchte ich mich bedanken
wir möchten raten bei der
bundesregierung und vor allem bei
unserem bundesfinanzminister dass er
dieses sondervermögen hier verhandelt
hat damit wir die bundeswehr ausrüsten
können und ich möchte mich auch bei den
genannten vier fraktionen bedanken dass
wir das hier so gemeinsam tragen denn es
ist keine selbstverständlichkeit dass
man in einer solchen krise auch
zusammensteht und dass dieser bundestag
ein so starkes signal setzen ich glaube
darauf können wir sehr stolz einmal
haben
in diese zeitenwende diese zeitenwende
hat zwei ganz wesentliche teile der
erste teil des besonders eilig und
dringend das ist die hilfe für die
ukraine
und dort haben wir uns entschieden
waffen zu liefern panzerfäuste stinger
sind geliefert wir werden schwere waffen
liefern panzerhaubitzen geparden und wir
tun das alles bei kindern im keller
sitzen während die wohnblöcke über ihn
und der artillerie feuer stehen wir tun
das alles damit das nicht ewig der
zustand ist mit tun dass damit auch die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer in frieden
und freiheit leben können auf diesem weg
sind ja einige schritte gegangen und wir
werden noch weitere gehen müssen und der
zweite wichtige teil ist eben das
sondervermögen über das wir heute reden
die bundeswehr ausrüsten wir wollen die
bundeswehr in die lage versetzen diese
republik zu verteidigen aber eben auch
unsere bündnispartner zu verteidigen wir
wollen das prinzip aufrechterhalten dass
es nicht von der größe eines landes an
an abhängt ob es sich selbst bestimmen
kann oder nicht sondern vom willen seine
bürgerinnen und bürger dass das in ganz
europa gilt es haben sicherlich viele
auch zum beispiel im baltikum noch gut
in erinnerung dass russische truppen
dort präsent waren wenn ich an die
hansestadt riga denke gibt es dort
sicherlich viele menschen die sie noch
daran erinnern dass russische truppen
vor ort waren das geht vielen menschen
in meiner heimatstadt der hansestadt
ständer auch so dann stehen
entschuldigen sie bitte kurz
es ist eine sehr große unruhe im saal so
dass wir dem redner nicht folgen können
ich bitte die damen und herren
kolleginnen und kollegen platz
einzunehmen die debatte folgen wollen
und die andere bittet den raum zu
verlassen
das betrifft vor allem die stehenden
personen im hinteren teil des planes
holz
ich bitte sie hier den platz platz
einzunehmen der hier bleiben möchte und
wer der debatte nicht folgen will
bitte auch mal auf der auf der rechten
seite von meiner seite aus gesehen dass
wir hier gute die debatte weiter
fortführen können vor allem bei der
wichtigkeit des themas
vielen dank herr faber sie können
fortführen vielen dank frau präsidentin
ich weiter bei betont habe dass die
menschen in der hansestadt riga
sicherlich keine russischen truppen mehr
in ihrer stadt haben wollen weil sich
noch gut daran erinnern wie es wie das
war das verbindet viele menschen in
europa in mittel und osteuropa nämlich
zum beispiel auch die unruhiger und
meiner heimatstadt der hansestadt
stellen also mit diesem sondervermögen
setzen wir eine klare botschaft dass sie
dafür auch keine angst haben müssen wir
nicht nur den willen haben und zu
verteidigen sondern dann auch die
fähigkeiten dafür haben wir dieses
sondervermögen meine damen und herren
wir werden damit die bundeswehr
ausrüsten wir werden das einhalten was
diese bundesregierung
mehrfach zugesagt hat bei der nato nehme
ich das zwei prozent ziel einzuhalten
wir setzen ein klares signal richtung
russland wir haben verteidigungs
kapazitäten in deutschland und europa
und wir werden etwas beenden was viel zu
lange hier normalzustand war nämlich
dass man die bundeswehr kaputt sparen
wir wurden werden die bundeswehr
ausrüsten wir werden da altes gerät
durch ein neues gerät ersetzen und wir
werden dafür sorgen dass auch genug
material da ist ein beispiel dafür
meine damen und herren wir haben wohl
tag 100 von putins angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine und wir haben für zwei tage
munition
der nato standards sind 30 tage allein
und diese lücke zu schließen müssen wir
investieren und wir müssen auch
investieren im panzer hubschrauber und
wir müssen investieren den kampfjets und
ich glaube niemand hier hat sein
politisches engagement damit begonnen
weil er das machen will aber wir müssen
es heute machen um die zivilen
investitionen die wir durchführen zu
erhalten um ihren bestand zu sichern und
auch unser gesellschaftsmodell zu
sichern und damit auch frieden und
freiheit in europa und wir werden das
auf einer art uhr wir wären markt
verfügbares material kaufen und wir
werden zeitgleich den beschaffungs den
beschaffungsprozess reformieren damit
das gerät auch schnell in der truppe
ankommt denn es geht hier um die
sicherheit nicht nur unseres landes
sondern das gesamten europäischen
kontinents deswegen bitte ich sie alle
gehen sie in sich und stimmen sie diesen
sondervermögen zu vielen dank
das plädoyer von marcus faber
gesetzentwurf diözesen fraktion
zuzustimmen nächste redner ist johann
wadephul stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unterwäsche
und kollegen wir
verabschieden heute ein
gesetzespaket
wir verabschieden ein gesetzespaket was
eine
grundgesetzänderung beinhaltet und auf
der anderen seite ein bundeswehr
vermögens und bundeswehr
finanzierungsgesetz beinhaltet und das
ist ein novum für den deutschen
bundestag und ich sage dass wir wieder
einen besonderen gruß an oberst wüster
und seine kameraden und kameraden dass
eine neue selbstverpflichtung des
deutschen bundestages des gesetzgebers
dass er genauso wie die bundesrepublik
deutschland verpflichtungen
international insbesondere nato rahmen
übernimmt
fähigkeiten bereitzustellen auf der
anderen seite auch die finanziellen für
die bundeswehr bereit erstellt das heißt
verpflichtung und finanzielles geben
kommen jetzt in einen einklang das ist
eine völlig neue sache die hat es in der
bundesdeutschen ahnt noch nicht gegeben
das werden wir jetzt erstmal hier uns
selber binden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen festlegen und ich bitte sie um
unterstützung war für die cdu csu
fraktion ein zentrales ziel in den
verhandlungen die wir geführt haben
dass es notwendig ist und dass das
wortwörtlich herr kollege klingbeil auch
dass zwei prozent ziel umfasst dass es
eine notwendigkeit gab auch das noch
einmal zu fixieren und mit ihnen zu
diskutieren das hat sich ja nicht nur in
der letzten legislaturperiode gezeigt wo
sie nicht müde geworden sind
das zwei prozent ziel nicht nur verbal
zu attackieren sondern auch innerhalb
der koalition des uns zu verunmöglichen
es schon früher zu erreichen sondern
selbst diese debatte hat das ja noch
einmal gezeigt die einzige fraktion die
ohne wenn und aber hinter dem
bundeskanzler gestanden hat wenn es um
das zwei prozent ziel gegen war die cdu
csu fraktion dass es bemerkenswert genug
in dieser situation
weil der spd fraktion haben das auch
unterstützen nein ich will dass in einem
ernst sagen der kollegen bei sie gesagt
haben der 24
februar ist natürlich eine zeitenwende
gewesen aber ehrlich gesagt die gab es
schon vorher haben sie die krim aktion
vergessen haben sie den überfall
russlands auf die ost ukraine vergessen
das war schon die erste zeitenwende und
damals sind schon zwei prozent
verabredet worden und sie waren nicht
bereit gehen zu folgen ich möchte im
übrigen sagen zu der bemerkung die sie
zum thema der bewaffneten drohnen
gemacht haben die fand ich in jeder
hinsicht unangemessen
es war die spd bundestagsfraktion die
gegen den koalitionsvertrag der mit uns
geschlossen worden ist in der letzten
legislaturperiode
verhindert hat dass bewaffnete drohnen
angeschafft worden sind das hat
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
schutzlos zurückgelassen das hat die
schafft den beschaffungs weg unnötig
verzögert und ihr
hier sie sagen ist eine lüge warum es
denn fritz felgentreu zurückgetreten man
muss sich ja schon für so ein
parteivorsitzende ihr eigener vertreibt
ihr eigener verteidigungspolitischer
sprecher ist deswegen zurückgetreten
hört sich doch noch mal und erleben sie
noch mal nach weshalb er das gemacht hat
weil er es nicht mehr mit seinem
gewissen verantworten konnte als
aufrechter sozialdemokrat sie haben die
bundeswehr sie haben fritz felgentreu
und andere im stich gelassen damit sie
nicht das ist die wahrheit das ist die
wahrheit das muss hier noch mal gesagt
werden
es ist bemerkenswert genug er möchte
nicht dass sie in dieser woche dass zwei
prozent ziel als eine absurde zahl
bezeichnen die ihr bundeskanzler hier im
deutschen bundestag in die debatte
geworfen hat und über den gesetzestext
stimmen wir jetzt ab wir stimmen jetzt
über ihre absurde zahl ab und ich schaue
mir an wie sie abstimmen
ich schaue mir an wie sie abstimmen ob
worte und taten der an der stelle
zusammentreffen und ich will das auch
noch mal zu dazu der frage sagen wie das
geld verwarnt wird ich habe das schon in
anderen debatte ja wir haben überhaupt
keine differenz dabei dass die bric
deutschland über das sondervermögen
hinaus weitere sicherheitspolitische
verantwortung hat weitere aufgaben zu
erledigen hat im cyber bereich bei der
verkehr bei den vorkehrungen die wir im
zivilschutz zu treten zu treffen haben
und so weiter und zwar das ist völlig
unstreitig aber es gibt ja für
sicherheitspolitische ausgaben nicht nur
das sondervermögen sondern weiter in den
10 toren 14 und auch die ndr des
innenministeriums und weitere etats des
außenministeriums die alle dafür
richtigerweise verwandt werden was war
das möchte ich schon noch mal sagen frau
außenministerin weil sie heute hier
wieder einen völlig neuen aspekt in die
diskussion eingebracht haben und jetzt
in simuliert haben die unions fraktion
wäre dagegen im europäischen rahmen
unterstützungen finanzielle
unterstützung zu leisten wie
sind bereit innerhalb der europäischen
union dazu beizutragen dass die
gemeinsame verteidigung
sicherheitspolitik unterlegt wird wir
sind bereit darüber nachzudenken wie wir
mehr auf europäischer ebene auch
sicherheitspolitische militärisch
zusammenarbeiten können wenn sie das
wollen bitteschön gerne aber halten sie
uns nicht dinge vor die in der gesamten
diskussion der letzten wochen überhaupt
keine rolle gespielt haben wir sind
schlicht und ergreifend für nicht mehr
und nicht weniger eingetreten und das
ist eben in der tat kollege mittelberg
habe das anfangs gesagt dringend
notwendig angesichts des ausrüstungs
zustandes der bundeswehr dass das
gesamte geld des sondervermögens für die
bundeswehr verwandt wird alles für die
bundeswehr das ist an dieser stelle die
richtige entscheidung das ist auch die
richtige sicherheitspolitische
entscheidung und wenn wir das gemeinsam
heute hier im bundestag beschließen dann
sind wir einen entscheidenden schritt
weiter insbesondere für die soldatinnen
soldaten vielen dank
johann wadephul für die unions fraktion
jedoch mit deutlich die andere auf lars
klingbeil und die haltung der spd unter
anderem ging es darum den streit um
unbewaffnete
unbewaffnete ungenannten werden und ist
ein guter tag ist ein guter tag für die
bundeswehr darf hier einige generelle
und
begrüßen ist aber ein guter tag für die
menschen in unserem land es geht um
freiheit es geht um demokratie und
beides wird durch diese sondervermögen
gestärkt die zeitenwende wird somit mit
leben erfüllt und diese zeitenwende wird
sicher auch noch in vielen anderen
bereichen unseres lebens noch
anzutreffen seien 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich für die bundeswehr ein klares
zeichen in die welt in diesen unruhigen
zeiten damit wir die bundeswehr in der
lage seien die gestiegenen anforderungen
voll umfänglich zu erfüllen die die
bedrohungslage an uns stellt wir sorgen
für aus- und nicht für aufrüstung an
dieser stelle möchte aber auch einiges
mal grundsätzlich anmerken es macht
überhaupt keinen sinn unsere bundeswehr
ständig schlecht zu reden es macht
überhaupt keinen sinn auf die
soldatinnen und soldaten hier öffentlich
auf darauf zu dreschen unsere
soldatinnen soldaten haben mehr respekt
verdient weil eines können auch zur
wahrheit dazu dass wir bisher alle in
unseren bündnisverpflichtungen
nachgekommen sind und das vollumfänglich
und was noch auch zur wahrheit dazu
gehört und ich glaube das wissen auch
die soldatinnen und soldaten es ist eine
parlamentsarmee und niemand hier in
diesem haus schickt soldatinnen und
soldaten
ungeschützt in einsätze nie und nimmer
und das thema drohne
nicht eine anmerkung machen darf es hat
schon seinen grund warum die ministerin
lamprecht sehr schnell im
beschaffungswesen veränderungen und
beschleunigung bringen musste das war
auch ein thema bei der tonen thematik
das davor lagen halt auch nicht
rechtzeitig uns erreicht haben meine
damen und herren welche botschaften sind
werden unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
die menschen im land an europa und in
die nato deutschland kümmert sich um
seine parlamentsarmee wir stellen uns
unsere verantwortung wir sind ein
starker und vor allen dingen ein
verlässlicher bündnispartner
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger im land
fortschrittliche verteidigungspolitik
sozialpolitik klima und
wirtschaftspolitik wird weiterhin
gemeinsam in diesem land gedacht und
umgesetzt und nichts wird gegeneinander
ausgespielt und das ist auch ganz
richtig dass wir den zusammenhalt in
dieser gesellschaft in frieden und
freiheit sichern und stärken und
deswegen brauchen wir das sondervermögen
dieser russische angriffskrieg hat uns
wieder gelernt wer ohne angst in
freiheit leben will braucht einen
starken staat zum einen und er braucht
eine starke
verteidigungsarmee um diese freiheit zu
schützen aber auch zu garantieren viele
in den letzten jahren aufgetretenen
lücken in der militärischen ausrüstung
können nun beseitigt werden wir legen im
prinzip eine neue friedensdividende
von der persönlichen ausrüstung der
soldaten und soldaten und die haben ja
schon einiges in die wege geleitet über
munition bis hin zu schwerem gerät auch
für land wasser und luft wird die
bundeswehr in der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
in vollen umfang hier verstand
einhergehend mit der bereits von der
verteidigungsministerin eingeleiteten
beschleunigung des beschaffungswesen und
das war eines der hauptgründe warum
vieles hier nicht gelaufen ist und dem
und der neuen voraussetzung dass wir
sagen wir kaufen markt verfügbare und
bewährte systeme damit werden wir hier
vieles beschleunigen und damit ist auch
schluss mit euren entwicklungslösungen
und vor allen dingen der oft zitierten
deutschen goldrand lösungen denn wir
müssen hier die ps auf die straße
bringen das erwarten die soldatinnen und
soldaten aber auch die menschen von uns
und ich muss zum selbst zu setzen auch
zu recht hierzu haben wir auch im
haushaltsausschuss schon entsprechende
beschlüsse gefasst um das verfahren eng
zu begleiten meine damen und herren dann
jahren die union dass sie sich ihrer
staatspolitischen verantwortung bewusst
geworden sind und wir stehen heute hier
zusammen dass auch ein zeichen einer
starken demokratie
zum schluss hat sich die chance dass
jedes über das sondervermögen vorgesehen
der beschaffungsvorgang dass der über 25
millionen euro auch weiterhin dem
haushaltsausschuss vorgelegt werden muss
wir werden das also zeitnah und auch
kritisch begleiten dafür herzlichen dank
und es ist ein guter tag für unsere
bundeswehr dankeschön
die afg fraktion sieht diese
kreditaufnahme über ein sondervermögen
als nicht zulässig anhand deswegen hier
auch einen änderungsantrag
eingereicht
und für die afg fraktion als nächstes
versucht gleich gerald gerold otte
sprechen er sitzt im
verteidigungsausschuss ist auch ob man
im unterausschuss abrüstung
rüstungskontrolle und nichtverbreitung
und eben gerade hat auch yvonne mag was
die abstimmung zur grundgesetzänderung
geschlossen
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen die bundeswehr kann schon
seit jahren ihren verfassungsmäßigen
auftrag nämlich die landesverteidigung
sicherstellen nicht erfüllen die
verantwortung für diesen
verfassungsbruch tragen weil ich die
soldaten und zivilen mitarbeiter der
bundeswehr die treu ihren dienst für
unser land leisten
verantwortlich sind alle
bundesregierungen seit 1990 und diese
stützenden fraktionen
sie verantworten eine politik die
deutschland streitkräfte bis in die
grundfesten erschüttert hat
das verteidigungsministerium war 16
jahre unionsgeführte davor sieben jahre
von der spd sie alle sind verantwortlich
für den desolaten zustand der bundeswehr
gerne wird es einfach nur noch
lächerlich wenn wir auch wie wir gerade
gesehen haben immer wieder die vertreter
links links gelben koalition der cdu csu
sich hier gegenseitig versagen vor
halten werden sie erwachsen und stehen
sie zu ihren fehlern
meine damen und herren die vielzitierte
friedensdividende wir haben heute auch
schon da gehört seit langem für einen
kräftigen malus für die streitkräfte
geworden es hätte auch gar nicht erstes
weckruf durch den krieg russlands gegen
die ukraine bedurft und das zu erkennen
es ist höchste zeit deutschlands
verteidigungsfähigkeit
wiederherzustellen und die langjährigen
versäumnisse von union und spd
aufzuarbeiten
die einsatzbereitschaft der deutschen
streitkräfte muss zukünftig aber auch
unabhängig vom konkreten
sicherheitspolitischen ereignissen wie
zb im aktuellen krieg in der ukraine
garantiert sein
hiervon alternative für deutschland
haben das bereits sehr früh angemerkt
und haben immer wieder konstruktive
vorschläge gemacht und die zweckmäßige
und umfassender sind als das was wir uns
hier heute vorlegen
in einem punkt sind wir uns aber einig
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
sind dringend notwendig die bereitschaft
erkennen aber auch ohne
grundgesetzänderung zur
schuldenfinanzierung und zur umgehung
der grundgesetzlich verankerten
schuldenbremse erreicht werden können
sind der einzig und allein des
politischen willen gedurft die
erforderliche mittel jetzt und künftig
in den verteidigungshaushalts
einzustellen die mittel werden aber nach
meiner einschätzung zunächst einmal nur
die drängendsten probleme bei
ausrüstungen material munition lösen
können
wenn jemand ihn wieder aufbauen der
streitkräfte ernsthaft betreiben wollen
braucht die bundeswehr deutlich mehr
geld und das auch über längeren zeitraum
das erfordert zwangsläufig einen
stetigen und berechenbaren aufwuchs des
verteidigungshaushalts
mit den mitteln dieser sonder schulden
soll gemäss der projektliste des
ministeriums auch ein großteil der
beschaffung aus dem ausland kommen viele
können sich und das zu recht nicht damit
anfreunden dass nun nicht vorrangig
deutsche unternehmen beauftragt werden
sondern vor allem us-amerikanische
waffen mit deutschem steuergeld gekauft
werden
grübel ihr vorrecht der bundesregierung
auf schaffen sie die voraussetzungen und
führen die verpflichtende ost
vereinbarungen bei rüstungsgeschäften
mit ausländischen lieferanten ein alle
normalen nationen machen dass nur
deutschland nicht dann sind nämlich die
lieferanten verpflichtet gelder in
deutschland zu reinvestieren etwa die
endmontage die wartung oder die
herstellung von ersatzteilen ist eine
klassische win win situation gerade im
hinblick auf die anstehenden groß
angelegten rüstungsbeschaffung sind oft
vereinbarungen dringend geboten aber die
bundesregierung zeigt er keinerlei
interesse
und lässt unseren vor allem kleine und
mittelständische unternehmen milliarden
investitionen ohne grund entgehen
meine damen und herren die wieder
herstellen der verteilungsbericht auf
deutschlands und der kampfkraft der
bundeswehr wird mehrere
legislaturperioden in anspruch nehmen
diese langzeit aufgabe kann aber nur auf
der basis einer gefestigten
gesellschaftlichen akzeptanz für den
anspruch an den start ist auch
selbstbehauptung gelingen die äußere
sicherheit unseres landes muss deshalb
wieder einen herausgehobenen stellenwert
im kollektiven bewusstsein der
bevölkerung erlangen kommen sie bitte
zum schluss ja zwei sätze erst die wahl
ist für die notwendige politische
durchhaltefähigkeit zum wiederaufbau der
bundeswehr denn diese wird entscheiden
dafür sagen dass unser land künftig in
der lage sein wird die sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitischen erwartungen
seiner bürger und der bündnis forderte
die bündnispartner zu erfüllen vielen
dank
gerold orten war das und die abstimmung
läuft doch noch die abstimmung und bitte
die schriftführerin und schriftführer
mit der auszählung zu beginnen
nun werden also die stimmen gezählt
491 stimmen braucht ist um das
grundgesetz zu ändern in kürze werden
wir wissen wie die abgeordneten bisher
abgestimmt haben
jetzt erst einmal sebastian schäfer für
bündnis 90/die grüne ist obmann im
haushaltsausschuss
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen 100 tage nach beginn der
brutalen eskalation durch putins truppen
beschließen wir heute ein sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr in höhe von 100
milliarden euro
das wird der ukraine nicht direkt und
unmittelbar helfen es ist und bleibt
eine große und dringende aufgabe die
unterstützung für die ukraine und für
den freiheitskampf der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer zu beschleunigen und zu
verstärken auch mit schweren machen wir
haben vor wenigen wochen mit breiter
mehrheit einen beschluss gefasst der
gezeigt hat dass die demokratische mitte
dieses hohen hauses in dieser
überzeugung verbunden ist
uns verbindet auch die überzeugung
unsere freiheit entschlossen und mutig
zu verteidigen das berührt alle bereiche
von gesellschaft und politik die
verteidigung unserer freiheit braucht
auch die bereitstellung robuster
militärischer mittel in der absicht und
in der hoffnung die sie nie benutzen zu
müssen es ist eine grundlage unserer
freiheit uns verteidigen zu können
mit dem sondervermögen geben wir
wichtige schritte voran und reagieren
damit entschlossen auf die veränderte
sicherheitslage die verhandlungen zum
sondervermögen wurden von unseren
internationalen partnern sehr genau
beobachtet und
deutschland übernimmt entschieden
verantwortung in europa und in der nato
mit dem sondervermögen ermöglichen wir
nun die verlässliche beschaffung von
ausrüstung
gerade bei hochkomplexen militärgütern
wie schiffen helikoptern oder flugzeugen
sorgen wir dafür dass projekte nicht
weiter verzögert werden das hat in der
vergangenheit oft zu hohen kosten
beigetragen auch die industrie kann sich
jetzt vorbereiten und entsprechende
produktionskapazitäten schaffen 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen sind 100
milliarden euro neue kredite wir geben
geld aus das wir nicht haben geld das in
der zukunft erwirtschaftet werden muss
von den bürgerinnen und bürgern
entsprechend groß ist unsere
verantwortung deshalb ist es so
elementar wichtig dass wir das geld
effektiv und effizient verwendet
wie kann das gelingen
bei der beschaffung gibt es mehrere
stellschrauben wie wir die bundeswehr
besser und schneller ausrüsten können
politik und bundeswehr müssen
realistische ziele und vorgaben
vereinbaren wir müssen uns jetzt auch
trauen auf die 80 prozent lösung zu
setzen anstatt die die perfektion
anzustreben so können projekte leichter
im zeit und kostenrahmen bleiben es geht
aber auch darum
beschaffungsprozesse und
vergabeverfahren zu optimieren erste
schritte zur entschlackung hat die
ministerin mit der anhebung der vergabe
grenze und der erleichterten
auftragsvergabe schon auf den weg
gebracht zudem haben wir als ampel
haushälter weitere möglichkeiten durch
die verdopplung des handgeld für
kommandeure geschaffen etwas weniger
zentralismus und mehr entscheidungen vor
ort ermöglicht dass sich das
beschaffungsamt auf die wirklich
komplexen beschaffungen konzentrieren
kann
ministerin lambrecht hat zudem einen
beschaffungs beschleunigungsgesetz
angekündigt da geht es in erster linie
um vergabeverfahren wir setzen auch
darauf dass weitere formen jetzt zügig
angegangen werden und das muss über die
beschleunigung hinausgehen im
haushaltsausschuss haben wir eine
berichtspflicht zu fortschritten bei der
reform der kraft der beschaffung
beschlossen bei der auch der
rechnungshof diesen prozess kritisch
begleiten wird wo gibt es noch
verbesserungspotenzial
wir müssen einfach beschaffen durch die
beschaffung von markt verfügbaren
systemen also fertig entwickelten
funktionierenden dingen werden wir
schneller und günstiger einkaufen können
zumal wenn wir europäisch und
international abgestimmt agieren
ein zentraler punkt ist natürlich auch
das beschaffungsamt in koblenz dort
fehlt es an personal und hier und da
auch an expertise gleichzeitig möchte
ich aber auch betonen dass bei aller
berechtigten kritik an einzelnen
projekten auch vieles gut läuft so hat
das beschaffungsamt in den letzten
jahren deutlich mehr verteidige
abgeschlossen als in den jahren zuvor
aber natürlich besteht weiter
optimierungspotenzial
ich bin froh dass wir eine breite
mehrheit gefunden haben für das
sondervermögen und bin den kolleginnen
und kollegen von der union dankbar für
die unterstützung unserer koalition
als grüne hätten wir die vorteile des
sondervermögens auch für die so
wichtigen bereiche der cyber sicherheit
und des zivilschutzes genutzt wie
zentral cyber abwehr ein zivilschutz für
eine armee und für die
landesverteidigung sein kann bekommen
wir in der ukraine vor augen geführt
diese so dringend notwendigen
investitionen müssen nun an anderer
stelle im bundeshaushalt finanziert
werden das ist unsere verantwortung und
das werden wir im herbst bei den
haushaltsverhandlungen umsetzen
mit dieser entscheidung zum
sondervermögen heute können wir leider
nicht alle herausforderungen für unsere
bundeswehr lösen es bleibt eine große
aufgabe neben der modernisierung der
ausrüstung muss es dabei ganz zentral um
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten gehen
den ich an dieser stelle meinen
ausdrücklichen dank für ihren dienst
aussprechen möchte
die demographie ist eine große
herausforderung für uns ein arbeitsmarkt
insgesamt und für die bundeswehr ganz
besonders es muss uns gemeinsam gelingen
junge menschen für den dienst in der
bundeswehr zu begeistern wir tragen
gemeinsam große verantwortung für unsere
parlamentsarmee herzlichen dank
und der nächste redner jan korte
fraktion die linke
die hatte präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren das in der
tatort ein historischer tag ist vor
allem ein schlimmer politischer tag den
wir heute haben denn wir werden gleich
leider gottes mit einer sehr großen mehr
das wohl größte auf rüstungsprogramm in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik hier
verabschieden und genosse klingen weil
es ist auch das größte
militarisierung abkommen was hier gleich
entschieden werden muss achten sie mal
auf die sprache allein hier im hause die
man sich abfahrt für schuss munition man
wohin liefert wo sind wir eigentlich hin
gekommen man erkennt sie an der straße
ihre kollegen kollegen und dass wir auch
mal zu uns ganz klar zu sagen leider
wird es heute kein 60 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für den unfassbaren
investitionsstau in den krankenhäusern
geben weiß nicht ob sie die meldung
gesehen haben auf den kinder-
intensivstation in diesem land können
zurzeit ein drittel der betten nicht
belegt werden wegen fehlendem personal
dafür heute haben wir haben wir mal ruck
zuck 100 milliarden euro 2 es gibt kein
46 milliarden euro sondervermögen um die
maroden schulen die staatlichen maroden
schulen in diesem land mal auf
vordermann zu bringen man muss man sein
kind einmal erklären wenn sie fragen
warum eigentlich schuld roulette so
aussieht wie es ist und sagt ja mensch
darf lösung im bundestag kein geld da
aber für panzer und ratschen ist geld da
das ist eine aberwitzige politikum das
auch in aller klarheit gesagt sie haben
sie mitbekommen
im rahmen des g 7 aussenministerin im
rahmen des g 7 gipfels gab es den
hilferuf der vereinten nationen das akut
4,2 milliarden euro benötigt werden um
eine sich anbahnende hungerkatastrophe
in afrika zu bekämpfen
allein in somalia sind laut zahlen
nationen
350.000 kinder akut vom hungertod
bedroht die deutsche beteiligung ich
will dass wir machen den vergleich rufen
am world food programm ist 70 millionen
euro
das ist übrigens exakt die höhe nämlich
genau die hälfte
das was wir heute beschließen von einem
f 35 kampfjets der kostet 145 millionen
euro was für eine perverse und
angesichts des zustandes in afrika und
ich will ihnen auch noch mal sagen es
gab ja in der spd einige von den älteren
sind ja noch dabei sie hatten ja früher
mal zumindest in diesen fragen eine
gefestigte position und auch bei den
grünen sind ja noch ein paar von den
ergrauten kolleginnen und kollegen dabei
es gab damals den richtigen ausbruch
kollege mützenich kollege trittin den
richtigen ausbruch rüstung tötet auch
ohne krieg das ist die wahrheit und
deswegen so hat das mit der linken
niemals möglich sein dass die minister
immer noch diese fahne hoch liebe
kollegen
ich möchte zum schluss kommen oder ich
muss leider natürlich das ist ja
bedauernswerten schluss kommen und
könnte jetzt noch viele war eine
unseriöse beschaffungspolitik und so
weiter und so fort sagen das hat ja der
sicherheitspolitische sprecher der
grünen tobias linder ist jetzt ein
bedeutend zum studium gemacht dass das
so nicht geht und ich will zum schluss
sagen es ist ja bei ihnen also man hat
ja manchmal auch mit der eigenen partei
oder mit der eigenen fraktion und ist
nicht so zufrieden oder auch mal genervt
heute ja erst grün völlig fremd so was
aber heute will ich mal sagen auch ich
bin manchmal von meiner partei genervt
das kommt selten vor aber heute bin ich
froh und stolz der einzigen partei
anzugehören die diesen ausrüstungs
wahnsinn nicht mit macht und auch
niemals mitmachen vielen dank
ihren korte war das hat sie sich
deutlich ausgesprochen
entscheidendes bundeswehr
sondervermögens gesetz und auch die
grundgesetze vom kracher nasa spricht
jetzt für diese zeit immer geraten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren werte
kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin als
junger neue abgeordnete mit großen
zielen und großen idealen in dieses
mandat gestartet und das ist noch immer
so denn die großen aufgaben haben sich
ja nicht verändert und liegen noch immer
vor uns was sich aber verändert hat ist
die situation ja die welt in der wir
agieren und ich persönlich werde mich
nie dafür entschuldigen dass meine spd
bis zum schluss versucht hat den
diplomatischen weg zu gehen
putins völkerrechtswidriger
angriffskrieg auch die ukraine hat uns
alle und damit die internationale
sicherheits ordnung tief erschüttert und
neue zeiten erfordern neue wege wir
diskutieren heute das sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr in höhe von 100
milliarden euro das hat auch bei mir wie
bei so viel im progressiven spektrum
erstmal keine freudentänze aufgelöst so
ehrlich wirklich sein aber und das ist
ein wichtiges großes aber wir müssen
jetzt verantwortung übernehmen
wir müssen aufhören damit uns bei
unserer verteidigung darauf zu verlassen
dass unsere bündnispartner das schon
machen wir müssen uns unsere rolle in
diesem bereich annehmen und wir müssen
aber gleichzeitig für sozialen frieden
und zusammenhalt hier bei uns in
deutschland sorgen jetzt ist mehr denn
je die zeit
immer und soziale sicherheit zusammen zu
denken das hat ist das sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr ein vernünftiger weg
um unsere bundeswehr unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten endlich vernünftig
auszustatten denn sie sind es doch die
buchstäblich an vorderster front für
unsere sicherheit stehen das ist doch
eine frage des respekts und in diesen
zeiten merken wir mehr als überfällig
sie endlich ordentlich auszustatten und
ihn funktionieren das gerät auf der höhe
der zeit an die hand zu geben
dieses sondervermögen ist auch deshalb
ein vernünftiger weg weil es unseren
haushalt nicht belasten wird denn er
soll uns ja in die lage versetzen so
viele wichtige gerade soziale projekte
umzusetzen gehen sie müssen ihre
krabbelgruppe bekannt noch kein problem
das interessiert hier niemanden
denn wir wollen die junge familie ist
mit der kindergrundsicherung
unterstützen damit eben kein kind nahe
abhängig ist vom einkommen ihrer eltern
denn wir wollen die jungen lageristin
irgendwann mit einem ordentlichen
bürgergeld unterstützen falls sie auf
den sozialstaat angewiesen sein sollte
denn wir wollen und wir müssen den
sozialstaat zu ende geht weiter
entwickeln dass menschen respektiert und
sie aufhängt anstatt sie zu gängen oder
steine in den weg zu legen wir müssen
unseren sozialstaat zu punkt 6 ma
schwerte kolleginnen und kollegen und
das können wir am besten mit einem gut
aufgestellten haushalt lassen sie uns
das eine tun ohne das andere sein lassen
zu müssen das bild und entweder zum
schluss
war schön aber dass für die
spd-fraktion
bisschen hart auf ich sie antworten hat
er die politische sprecher der
unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
krieg in europa gehört seit dem 24
februar nicht mehr der vergangenheit an
sondern ist knallhart in unser leben
zurückgekehrt sie sehen jeden tag
schreckliche bilder aus der ukraine oder
völkerrechts wie die russische
angriffskrieg bietet die zeiten in denen
wir in europa nur von freunden umgeben
waren sind vor auf sind vorbei darauf
müssen wir vorbereitet sein eine werft
demokratie benötigt eine schlagkräftige
bundeswehr denn nur eine voll
ausgestattete und voll ausgerüstete
bundeswehr ist in der lage unsere
demokratie unsere freiheit und unser
land vor bedrohungen und von außen von
außen zu schützen
da sind in diesen zeiten 100 milliarden
euro zusätzlich für die bundeswehr eine
sehr gute nachricht es sind nachrichten
jedoch notwendig sind um eine echte
zeitenwende für die bundeswehr zu
bringen das sondervermögen hat das
potenzial die deutschen streitkräfte
wieder zu einer wirksamen bündnis armee
in europa zu rüsten die einigung in der
mitte der demokratischen parteien ist
für mich nicht nur herausragend und
richtungsweisend sondern ein mehr als
deutliches signal in unsere truppe
hinein an dieser stelle gilt mein dank
allen soldatinnen und soldaten aber auch
zivilen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern die jeden tag ihren dienst
in der bundeswehr verrichten ohne das
beste personal ist die beste ausrüstung
wertlos
geld allein reicht jedoch nicht
entscheidend ist dass jetzt die
bundeswehr als auftraggeber und die
industrie als auftragnehmer zügig hand
in hand arbeiten wir als politik können
dabei unterstützen indem wir aktiv die
rahmenbedingungen so gestalten dass
beschleunigte beschaffung möglich sind
ich nehme auch die zusage der
bundesverteidigungsministerium beim wort
und erwarte dass unverzüglich das von
ihr angekündigte beschaffungs
beschleunigungsgesetz in den bundestag
eingebracht wird frau lamprecht die
zukunft der truppe liegt jetzt in ihren
händen
abschließend möchte ich auch mit blick
auf die irritierenden worte des
bundeskanzlers in der wochenmitte
nochmals klarstellen wer meint
populistisch die reihe der
verteidigungsministerin und minister zu
nennen und damit den nachholbedarf der
truppe allein an ihnen fest zu machen
agiert unfair vielleicht sollte man
vielmehr fragen wer es an der
notwendigen unterstützung der minister
hat wissen lassen wer hat den
unstrittigen reformbedarf im
beschaffungswesen kalt gestellt wer den
schnelleren aufwuchs der mittel zum
erhalt der fähigkeiten verhindert
ich will damit nicht den einzigartigen
tag für unsere bundeswehr eintrüben war
so geht man nach den guten und
konstruktiven gesprächen nicht
miteinander um das war unwürdig mein
dank gilt aber ein die mit uns
verhandelt haben zunächst der spitze
unserer verhandlungsgruppe alexander
dobrindt und mathias middelberg
allerdings oft so warte folien florian
hahn danke für das gute mit anderen da
aber auch den ministern der ampel
regierung mit denen wir gute
konstruktive gespräche geführt haben und
allen die im hintergrund dafür gesorgt
haben dass wir heute eine gute
entscheidung für die bundeswehr treffen
können die abstimmung läuft die
abstimmung gleich wir zeigen wer hinter
den frauen und männern steht die uns im
notfalls mit ihrem leben verteidigen
danke
soweit christian haase und damit kommen
wir zum letzten redner zum bundeswehr
sondervermögens gesetz danach soll auch
das ergebnis zur abstimmung zur
grundgesetzänderung verkündet werden
jetzt erst einmal nicht
verkehrspolitische sprecher der spd frau
zu gewöhnt
verteidigungspolitischer sprechen
wenn die marine versorgung schule auf
sylt mich 2007 beschlossen worden wäre
würde ich ihnen dann längeren
aufenthalte empfehlen um ihre
erinnerungen aufzufrischen bei den
ganzen debatten die wir über die frage
geführt haben wie es denn mit dem
bewaffnung von drohnen aussieht
versuchten doch vor fast sechs jahren
man uns einfach mal in der letzten
sitzung des
verteidigungshaushalts ausschussvorlage
unterzuschieben die nicht diskutiert war
und dann passierte eine ganze zeit
nichts und mit blick auf einen
bundestagswahlkampf
tauchte das ganze thema auf ihren reihen
wieder auf das war eine eigenartige
strategie die dann den tag gelegt wurde
auf dem rücken der soldatinnen soldaten
bundestags wahlkampf zu machen weil
niemand hier hatte die absicht die
soldatinnen soldaten
schutzlos zurückzulassen schutzlos in
eine situation zu bringen weil nämlich
dort wo sie im einsatz waren war klar
dass diese drohung vor 20 24 bewaffnet
gar nicht da sein werden ihre
argumentation
ich bin da sehr viel bei der wahrheit zu
bleiben und darzustellen wie den abläufe
waren selbst wenn wir heute uns er damit
beschäftigen sollten nach vorne zu
schauen nach vorne zu gucken und da will
ich auch nur noch eins zu sagen wenn ihr
parteivorsitzender gestern versuchte an
der debatte über die wiedereinführung
der wehrpflicht zu eröffnen ist das doch
nichts anderes als ein ablenkungsmanöver
männern nichts anderes in der tasche hat
und an dieser stelle
auch daran zu erinnern dass es viel
verteidigungsminister weil er die
wehrpflicht abgeschafft hat gegen die
stimmen der sozialdemokraten wir können
noch viele viele punkte auf machen an
denen wir an die frage anschließend
können wird was eigentlich wo getan und
gemacht heute aber geht es um einen
guten tag für die bundeswehr deshalb
hören guten tag weil mit dem was wir mit
dem sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
beschließen genau die lücken schließen
die bundeswehr seit jahren immer wieder
selber beklagt das ist es auch gut dass
die grundlage dieses beschlusses das ist
was die bundeswehr selber für sich
definiert hat und festgestellt hat wo
die größten probleme sind den mit diesem
sondervermögen zu schließen sind
bekleidung und persönliche ausstattung
ja an der stelle ist es nicht einsehbar
dass die wii als frei voller vom himmel
fahren seit jahren einen neuen schirm
der auf ihre einsätze angepasst ist
nicht zu verfügung kam wenn das
entwickeln jahre seien dauernd ist das
keine lösung sondern das was wir
brauchen ist dass wir sehr kurzfristig
und sehr schnell und das ist das gute an
diesem programm auch das gute das
beschaffen was wir beschaffen können
weil es da ist dass wir keine
bestellliste nach dem motto wünsch dir
was abarbeiten weil andere der gern und
andere interessen hätten auch wenn es im
wahlkreis interessen geht sondern dass
sie uns einzig und alleine an den bedarf
der bundeswehr orientieren an dem was
sie braucht bündnis fliegt und
verpflichtungen zu erfüllen bei dem was
sie an der nato was in der nato in der
eu auch an bilateralen entwicklungen
angegangen haben und ich finde es
richtig und
wir sehen das mit oben druck gearbeitet
wird dass alle vorschläge die die
verteidigungsministerien jahr schon auf
den tisch gelegt hat wie wir das
beschaffungswesen schritt für schritt
aber zügig reformieren dass wir an
dieser stelle auch mit hochdruck uns an
die arbeit machen und uns jetzt in den
maschinenraum der beschaffung begeben um
das umzusetzen was wir hier an
sondervermögen beschließen ist es ein
gutes sondervermögen unsere partnerinnen
und partner weltweit guckten darauf in
nato und eu und ich glaube damit kommen
hier der verpflichtung nach und tragen
die verantwortung die wir an der stelle
auch verantwortlich tragen können vielen
dank und ich bitte um zustimmung weil
die soldatinnen soldaten schwer
missbraucht
und ich schliesse die aussprache und
komme an dieser stelle zurück zu
zusatzpunkt drei ich gebe ihnen das von
den schriftführern und schriftführung
ermittelte ergebnis der namentlichen
abstimmung über den gesetzentwurf zur
änderung des grundgesetzes artikel 87a
bekannt
abgegebene stimmen
mit ja haben gestimmt 5 167
mit nein haben gestimmt
96 enthaltungen 20 der gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen
also das grundgesetz wird im artikel
87a um drei sätze erweitert indem dieses
sondervermögen
errichtet werden kann
und hier im bundestag wird es ihr jetzt
mehrere abstimmungen geben also dass
bundeswehr sondervermögens gesetz muss
abgestimmt werden in dem noch mal ein
paar details geklärt werden
zu diesem bundeswehr sondervermögen
unter anderem wofür es genutzt wird
und
das ist zum beispiel für das nato ziel
von zwei prozent angerechnet wird
allerdings gibt es auch einen
änderungsantrag von der afg fraktion und
da die fdp fraktion beantragt hat das
über diesen änderungsantrag namentlich
abgestimmt wird wird zuerst über diesen
abgestimmt